nos gusta que cada quien se haga su
propia idea empezamos a reflexionar
sobre el amor los diferentes aspectos
del amor bello o doloroso aburrido o
excitante y sobre el impacto que ello
tendrá en el escenario
[Música]
como traduce la idea del amor en su ropa
pensando en las diferentes facetas del
amor su belleza el dolor que inflingen
su lado sexy o aburrido y como esas
diferentes emociones se expresan en
nuestra ropa para decirlo brevemente el
dúo newyorkino vaquera siempre se
inspiró del conjunto del látex negro
vestido por madison enigma ver la
reconocida película realizada por olivia
gasa jazz en
1996 el amor la seducción el juego del
mostrar esconder tan importante para la
moda tantos puntos de anclaje
disimulados en las colecciones de prêt à
porter invierno 2022 ya veces repetidos
hasta el exceso el diseñador de alsacia
víctor paint santo concibió para la
actriz philippe le guay bell y una de
las heroínas de la serie muy bien parís
un corsé capelinas sexualmente
extravagante
es muy amable lo conozco poco pero es
muy querido es alguien muy entusiasta
atento que tiene futuro es muy creativo
para mí es un pequeño golpe
es un joven
un pequeño gold ya que justamente se
estrenó donde jean paul gaultier
superposiciones de cinturones correas
ropa interior de cuero bienvenido al
fascinante mundo del cautiverio no se es
más bien un ambiente la película chicago
que me inspiró quería mujeres dramáticas
con cada una un personaje una historia
hablar sobre asesinas pero de hecho
quien mató no se sabe y me gusta contar
historias me encantan
cuentos mitológicos de pulsiones de vida
y muerte donde no se duda en hablar
libremente de historias de sexo si es
normal hoy en día se volvió casi tabú
y es una lástima porque no lo hay es
solo lógica a mí me gusta el lado sexy y
el lado afirmado pero también muy sexy
con oversize lo sexy es una actitud para
mí entonces
super sexy siempre sexy tórrido mis 5
esta es la idea un poco de la bruja y
del hada que se encuentran y es técnico
también en tyler greene esta se ven
cosas que tienen sentido para ser
vestidas y así encontremos piezas sobre
la top civil al hassani el performer
podría vestir también hay súper juegos
sobre saiz yo diría diariamente es una
super colección
[Música]
sentada en primera fila la artista y
diseñadora de lencería australiana
micaela stark fue sexy y muy sexy los
corsés en la ropa ajustada había un
vestido transparente y había una pluma
que rodeaba el cuerpo tan sexy soy
diseñadora de modas y me habría gustado
hacer algo con ese vestido jugar con la
desnudez las son sombras sobre el cuerpo
es una colección muy sexy
unos cuantos días más tarde nos reunimos
con micaela estar donde van zandt pues
ya esta vez desfila con un corsé que
ella misma fabricó con una intención de
liberación del cuerpo de las mujeres
micaela stark no duda en mostrar sus
senos pero eso no le gusta a todo el
mundo en especial a instagram que la
censura en su nueva cuenta sus senos
están pixelados y sus rollitos
sublimados
es horrible hay que luchar contra eso la
censura y la censura del cuerpo de las
mujeres en especial por eso es tan
divertido hacer shows como ese porque no
es grave
estamos en la cárcel es normal y todo el
mundo puede verlo en la vida real y
usted puede divertirse sin instagram van
zandt fucsia un diseñador visón tino
nacido en besançon en el este de francia
con una madre profesora de moda en un
liceo un abuelo sastre john galliano
como primer mentor el visón tino es una
emancipación era una colección sobre los
años 40 que le explicó en los países
nórdicos entonces los noruegos en
montaña que son campesinos de los años
1900 que vestían ropa muy tradicional me
dieron ganas de orientarme hacia los muy
altos trajes muy altos es contrastado y
todas estas piezas se pueden soltar
ellos quiere decir por ejemplo que hay
vestidos llenos de presiones en un
vestido usted tiene ocho vestidos ellos
quiere decir que cuenta con ocho
posibilidades de vestir lo
con mangas sin mangas sin cuello tortuga
con cuello tortuga usted siempre sale
ganador compra uno y cuenta cómo es
pero el ejemplo más bello de declaración
de amor es una exposición love print
love el amor trae amor cuando falleció
al ver real vas cuarenta y siete
diseñadores de modas se reunieron para
dedicarle un traje durante un desfile
para la nueva marca que acababa de
lanzar as factory
las exposiciones son poco comunes los
eventos culturales en el mundo que
transmiten valores se transmite saber
información es un pasado se cuenta una
historia pero no se transmiten valores
particulares esta exposición así pueda
parecer un poco ingenuo en nuestra parte
transmite un valor de amor y generosidad
y de fraternidad que eran todos valores
defendidos por alber elbaz a lo largo de
su vida y aquí todos los diseñadores de
moda con vida pueden hablar de ello
qué bella puede ser la moda cuando bajo
todas sus formas celebra el amor
[Música]